hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast titled automated optimization
of IgG production in show cells
presented by dr. mike kowalski staff
application scientist Beckman Coulter
life sciences dr. David appeal marketing
Applications Manager Forte bio a
division appalled Life Sciences we are
excited to bring you this educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by biologics by Danaher
biologics by Danaher is a combined team
effort from select Danaher company
molecular devices Beckman Coulter life
sciences and Paul forte bio combining
years of experience in scientific
knowledge they provide comprehensive
biologics solutions with the simplicity
of a single point of contact on julissa
Morozov lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin the presentation we have a few
important announcements to make I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing a
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and des offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the CD button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
to follow the process of obtaining your
credits now I'd like to introduce dr.
Mike Kowalski dr. Kowalski is a staff
application scientist in the drug
discovery and basic research group of
Beckman Coulter life sciences he
received his PhD in microbiology and
molecular genetics from Harvard
University
our second speaker today will be dr.
David appeal dr appeal is a marketing
Applications Manager with Paul Forte bio
in charge of manufacturing bioprocess
and QC applications David received his
PhD in chemistry at Tulane University
and held two post doctoral stints at
Rice University and at the Pacific
Northwest National Lab for complete bios
of both of our speakers please visit the
webinar registration page and click view
bio mic I will now turn it over to you
Thank You Julie and thank you everyone
for attending today as Julie mentioned
we'll be talking about some of our
collaborative work where we automated
the optimization of IgG production and
we'll show how this fits into a larger
Cho cell line development workflow a
brief agenda for the talk today we'll
begin by introducing the process of cell
line development and some of the steps
involved we'll focus on one specific
step which is media optimization for
improved IgG production and we'll
describe how we automated a design of
experiment approach to try and find the
optimal conditions for media growth I
will also touch on how we use multiple
different analyses and how this is a
portion of how this work became so
collaborative we will focus on analysis
using the paul 40 bio octet or IgG
production and then we'll show how we
use an imaging system and a plate reader
from molecular devices to measure cell
growth we'll also talk about some of the
caveats that we found during this
analyses and then we'll bring it all
back to show how this fits into the cell
line development workflow and how these
products can be integrated into a
complete cell line development system so
what is cell line development
well obviously the goal is to basically
produce high quantities of a protein of
interest from cultured cells which is
much easier than sounds much easier than
it actually is
and we'll walk through some of the main
steps of the workflow the first step is
to basically get yourself to start
producing your protein of interest and
this is typically done through
transfection although there are
obviously other ways to introduce your
plasmid of interest
following the transfection there's
usually a selection and or enrichment
step to basically ensure that all your
cells have taken in the plasmid and are
now starting to express your protein
following this this population is then
distributed to isolate single cells this
can either be done using a cell sorter
or some sort of limiting dilution
approach because you want your
population to start from a monoclonal
population and ensure that all your
cells have the same makeup following
this step you need to basically do a
screening assay to assess the protein
production that each well or each colony
is currently producing with the hopes of
finding not only the highest producer
but also the ones that are producing the
molecule that has the correct
characteristics once this has been
completed you would take your top hits
forward and then see if you can further
optimize the process to increase protein
production even further
once these optimal conditions are
established that's when you would move
to a scale up and move towards a
bioreactor type size of protein
production now there are a number of
challenges associated with this workflow
the first would be sample throughput not
only do the sample throughput change
dramatically throughout the process but
at its highest point such as during the
clone selection portion you can have
significantly high throughput and it's
essential to have sample preparation and
analysis systems that can meet this
throughput you also have concern for
sample and data integrity this workflow
can take place over weeks or even months
and you need to be able to ensure that
your samples are know where they are in
the system and any data that has been
generated is associated with those
samples and we have some hardware and
software solutions to enable this and
finally as I mentioned these campaigns
can take weeks or months and the sample
throughput because it can change so
radically really lends itself to trying
to stagger multiple campaigns on top of
one another so that you're really
maximizing the equipment that you have
set aside for utilization and we again
have some software solutions for this
challenge for now we're really just
going to focus on one aspect to kind of
do a deep dive and we're going to focus
on the process optimization step and
show how these different components can
be used for the
as I mentioned before this is
essentially pretty far down the stream
of cell line development but what we're
hoping to accomplish is once we have a
stable e expressing cell line to see if
we can optimize the media conditions to
really improve our IgG production even
further and the approach we took to
demonstrate this is a design of
experiment or a do we approach rather
than just looking at changing a single
variable at a time
the advantage of do E is that you can
combine different reagents different
concentrations of reagents different
times of addition or incubation or
really change any sort of variable that
you can think of and you would do this
in combination with changing other
variables the reason for this is that
you can readily identify what factors
have a significant impact on your system
you can also identify what factors do
not have a significant impact and you
can stop spending time or money or
effort trying to optimize these factors
further ideally you'll also be able to
detect some interactions between factors
and possible synergies that can
eventually lead you to identifying the
optimal conditions to push your system
to its maximal level the challenge with
this approach is that you quickly end up
with large numbers of conditions because
every time you add a new factor the
number of factors that you're testing
increases factorial e so things can
really spiral out of control very
quickly our approach for this was to use
a stable e expressing cho cell line
showed EP 12 which is expressing human
IgG against interleukin 8 the basal
media that we're seeking to optimize was
the optical media which already is has
been optimized for cho cell growth but
we were looking to see if we could push
things even further and increase the
protein production from our stable cell
line for this we chose to test a variety
of different additives that are commonly
used in cell culture particularly in
protein producing cell culture such as
poly amine Speight which is a mixture of
selenium pyruvate insulin transferrin
and ethanolamine glutimax which is a
more temperature stable form of
glutamine a frequently added amino acid
non-essential Immie amino acid solution
two different buffers as a way of trying
to
normalised the ph if we did have
increased cell growth
those were bioreactor pH adjustment
solution I will refer to it as
bioreactor buffer from now on as well as
the more commonly used haeppy's and one
more additive efficient feed a which is
made by the same manufacturer
manufacturer as optic oh and again it
suggested to help increase show cell
grow the conditions we were testing were
simply yes or no adding these different
additives so even with just these
essentially two concentrations plus or
minus the addition already the
combinations reached 96 different
mixtures simply from this relatively
small number of additives if we actually
increase that to add a second
concentration so that we had no addition
high and low the factorial nature of
this experiment would result in 1215
different combinations so you can see
how quickly this can spiral into pretty
difficult numbers to work with in
addition we wanted to have some
replicate wells to ensure that we had
reliable measurements and you can see
because of this 96 different mixtures
plus replicates this would definitely be
a workflow that would benefit from
automation that brings us to the biomech
automated workstations from Beckman
Coulter life sciences shown to the right
is one of our biomech iSeries
instruments the is 7 this is basically
just a liquid handler that has a variety
of different functions one pipetting
head is the span aid shown on the lower
left hand side which has eight
individual pipe cutters that can be
spread apart so you can access multiple
tubes and can also aspirate and dispense
different volumes at the same time shown
in the lower center image is the
multi-channel head this can be either a
96 or a 384 wellhead and those can be
changed between methods and it's also
shown featuring our selective tip
feature where you can load a single
column or a single row of tips a single
tip or even a clusters of tips really
any combination you can think of and
we'll show how this was really essential
for this deal we approached and shown on
the lower right hand side is the deck of
the instrument the deck is designed to
be flexible so you can have positions
that can hold tips or plates but you can
also have active positions that can heat
and cool that can shake order you can
also integrate different devices
an example of which is shown in the
upper right hand corner the biomech
itself is enclosed in a HEPA filtered
enclosure and this is was used to ensure
the sterility of the samples while we
were manipulating them you can also
integrate such things as incubators
shown on the far right-hand side of the
integrated system this enables the cell
to be brought on and sent back to the
incubator without manual intervention
and on the left hand side you can
integrate an analyzer or really on
either side as well as on the deck
itself and shown on the left is just one
of the analyzers we use for molecular
devices so this gives you an idea of
this system that was used will now walk
through the workflow itself and how we
approach the design of experiment so
shown here is just a 96 deep weld plate
where we started using this to combine
the different factors that we were
testing we use the span aid system to
add either media indicated by the minus
signs or spite or polyamine shown in
blue and red respectively
and as we established from the do e
approach we had combinations of all of
these reagents resulting in four
different conditions to start we next
use the span a to repeat the process
using media glutimax or non essential
amino acids shown in green and orange
respectively and plated those into 16
different combination wells and then use
the in selective tip feature the
multi-channel head to load for tips and
stamp our original four wells into those
16 wells in quadruplicate so we now have
16 different conditions of the combined
factors this step was repeated again
using the span a to dispense either
media haeppy's or bioreactor buffer
shown in yellow and pink outlines
respectively and we loaded 16 tips on
the multi channel head to again stamp
those original 16 conditions into our
new 48 wells we then brought on a second
96 well deep well plate and dispensed
either media or efficient feed a into 48
wells each loaded 48 tips onto the
multi-channel head and stamped that for
a total of 96 different conditions we
then loaded 96 tips onto the
multi-channel head and dispensed them
into quadruplicate wells about 384 well
plate again this adds challenge to
trying to do this manually because 384
well place our challenge to work with
but you can get an idea here of what the
plate layout looks like and the four
highlighted wells really just indicate
the four quadruplicate wells that happen
to feature Happy's glutimax by polyamine
non-essential amino acids and efficient
feed a so again in a single plate were
able to test 96 different conditions in
quadruplicate wells and my best estimate
to try and do this manually with that it
would have taken about a hundred and
eighty four manual transfers using both
single and multi-channel pipettes to do
this process that the biomech was able
to achieve in 20 minutes after all of
these reagents had been dispensed we
added cells to each of the wells and
incubated them for a variety of days
after which we would need the
opportunity to try and assay the
production of IgG to see which of our
factors was having the most impact and
for that we turn to the octet from Paul
for table and I'll turn it over to David
to tell you more about that thank you
Mike
so just a brief
production of the octet systems you know
that were used to monitor AGG expression
overtime there are four main octet
systems that differ mainly through
different tuples so we do have the low
throughput octet k2 which is a two
channel instrument essentially capable
of measuring two molecules
simultaneously
the next level of the octet systems
would be the third generation octet red
ninety-six II which is capable of
measuring simultaneously eight samples
at a time in addition to that a channel
instrument we do have the octet red 384
which is a 16 channel instrument and
therefore capable measuring 16 samples
at a time and then finally we do have
the octet HDX which is Paul for the
valslide sheep octet instrument capable
of measuring as many as 96 samples at
the same time the last two instruments
the octet 384 and the octet htx are
configured to be able to be integrated
to a liquid measuring device such as the
biomech so the different main difference
in terms of the sample input for the
instrument would also include the design
of the sample place and the barrel
sensor plates
so both the octet red 384 and the octet
htx
have two different sample compartments
where to sample plates either a 96-well
plate or a 384-well plate can be
inserted in addition all the instruments
do have a balancer rocking plate where
biosensor rocks contain e as many as 96
sensors as you can see in the schematic
in the diagram can be inserted a sense
about sensor which essentially a single
devices used for measuring each sample
at a time
essentially fiber optics materials that
are made also a glass tip at the end of
which there is a bio activated molecule
so Paul photo bio carries a variety of
these biosensors with different
biomolecules at the
covalently linked including protein a
and protein G which are essentially used
for measuring IgG titer
depending on the different isotopes of
the IgG
in addition to the protein and protein G
there are also other customizable
biosensor tape such as kept traveling
such as the main relative tips etc etc
depending on what kind of analysis one
once ran so in addition to the
biosensors what's required to be able to
run an essay on the octave instruments
would simply be a sample trail in
96-well or a 384-well sample tray so the
technology behind the octet systems the
object system are real-time label-free
biosensor analytical systems that
utilize bio layer interferometry
essentially when we talk about ballet
interferometry what we mean is that the
system measures the light interference
is you build a biological molecule at
the tip of the biosensor the bio sensor
itself which is schematically shown in
the diagram on the left hand side has
two surfaces one an internal reference
surface and the second a chemistry
sample surface at the tip of the
biosensor the two surfaces reflect light
independent of each other and deflect
them back to the detector so essentially
what the system does is that as you
build up a logical molecule through the
chemistry surface on the tip of the bio
sensor when you're binding a molecule
you essentially have two different light
reflection going back to the detector
that are captured remotely in the
instrument and then I used to be able to
then determine what the interference
pattern would look like as a result of
the building biological molecule so the
system then captures the intensity of
the light reflected as a function of
both wavelength and the distance between
the two surfaces essentially the
reference surface in the sample surface
so you can imagine as your concentration
changes or as your molecular weight size
changes you essentially expect the
intensity to change and also potentially
the shape of the wave length of the
sample waveguide to change system
therefore then this is and therefore
shows that the difference between the
lambda max or the reference waveguide
and the sample waveguide in real time so
what you see or the diagram at the
bottom is worth the user the analysis s
the analysis is going on in real time
and so for any given binding event where
one expects an association between two
molecules you should see a shift a
redshift in the in the wavelength that
ends up giving you a you know a positive
response signal before the other hand
one were wanted to look at the quality
of the reagent being analyzed one may
potentially move the sensors back into
bhava and be able to look at the
dissociation rate of the same molecule
so in addition to looking at binding
events one can also look at dissociation
events in the case of IgG fortification
the analysis basically stops only at the
binding event phase and does not
necessarily proceed to the dissociation
phase so with regards to this particular
experiment that we did essentially a
quantitation assay is one where you are
only looking at the binding event as
depicted in the figure in the middle of
the graph at the top where you can see
positive response on the y axis the
shifting binding wavelength as a
function of time there are three
different types of quantitation
experiments that can be done on the
octet you can either have a one-step
quantitation event known as a direct
quotation where the power sensors are
dipped into the sample in only one step
and measured or you could have a
situation whereby the sample being
analyte is fairly low in concentration
typically in the sub microgram per ml
concentrations where a sandwich acid
required in a sandwich assay would
typically happen either the biosensors
are dipped into the analyte and then dip
into a detection reagent similar to what
one would do in analyzer sandwich but
one could also exchange the analysis to
include the presence of substrates
especially when you want to measure very
low sub microgram per ml concentration
such as picogram
concentrations at the end of the
analysis what then done is that the
system then uses the the binding events
and analyzes the initial on rate of that
binding event and plots that as a
function of the sample concentration to
generate the binding rates of the
different concentrations in a standard
curve a reference curve the reference
curve is therefore then used to then
extrapolate what your unknown sample
concentrations would look like but in
addition to just idea quantitation or
any given molecule you know biomolecular
concentration in the determination the
octet can also be used for target ID
determination the okay can be used for
lead screening assays little
characterization preclinical development
assays and even QC and manufacturing
assays so for this study in question as
Mike mentioned earlier the cells were
incubated for a period of between three
to four days in general the LGG
quantitation
or the expression level determinations
can be done throughout the time course
of the asses so whether the cell
culturing is you know text you know as
low as two days or as many as one week
one could potentially be able to aliquot
the samples at any given time and be
able to fairly quickly measure the IgG
concentrations in a direct assay if the
expected expression levels are high or
in a sandwich a say if the expression
levels are extremely low in the case of
IgG and in the case of this study here
protein a biosensors that bind with the
FC region of the IgG were used in the
octet HT x which is the 96
biosensor 96 channel instrument the
highest throughput
octet instruments available was used you
know to allow for a fairly quick
analysis the samples were initially
first of all transferred using the
automated
biomech workstation excuse me mattresses
into blood cells and bottom plates
samples buses was also initially
prepared by regular by being
precondition in regeneration reagents so
again because we are dealing with IgG
here where we know that when an IgG
binds to protein a
we could potentially use low pH buffers
to be able to dissociate the a giggy's
binding we can use low pH buffers of 10
millimolar
glycine at pH 1.7 to be able to do the
regeneration and neutralize the buffer
and other neutral pH or in the actual
base system that's used for the IgG
expression the entire time spent for
preparing the samples essentially
transferring them it in the place was as
low as only seven minutes so seven
minutes to prepare the entire 384
samples into a sample plate the time for
doing the actual reads was only 20
minutes for the entire 384 samples so in
this case because we were expecting a
relatively high concentration so above
microgram per ml a simple direct read
was done here and that took only 20
minutes for the entire 3d for samples
and so in a typical IgG quantitation the
determination of the reference standard
curve is the first step and that
typically involves using a known
standard sample that is similar to the
analyte being audited the standard
sample is diluted in a dose-response
titration so in this case was from 50
micrograms per ml to 0.78 micrograms per
ml what's important here is that the
standard curve or the reference curve
needs to cover this part of the expected
expression levels so our estimation was
that we needed expression levels above
above 0.78 mark grams per ml but
potentially below 100 micrograms per ml
hence the range of 0.78 micrograms to 50
micrograms per ml the next assay would
then be to dip the sensors into the
unknown samples so the diagram is here
the bottom left would be what the 96
well in our known samples look like at
the different do ye conditions so again
the idea is to ensure that the cars for
the unknown samples fall in between your
lowest curve for the standard samples
and the highest careful standard samples
and then ultimately the initial slope
for the standard curve samples you know
are analyzed
extra poor to determine the binding
rates which are plotted on the y-axis as
a function of the known concentration of
the x-axis so the dots in blue would be
your standard curve combining rates as a
function of concentration and the ones
in red are the 96 samples which have the
unknown samples so as you can see they
fall very well in the middle of a curve
and therefore the standard curve can be
used to extrapolate the actual
concentrations they are known so we then
used after after determining the IDT
concentration we used a statistical
analysis essentially we used a
statistical software the particularly in
this list or the design expert 8.0 start
but one could potentially use any
statistical software such as such a jump
to be able to look at the interactions
between the different conditions so for
example the idea here was to identify
what the positive factors in the cell
culture supplement would be and also to
identify what supplements could
potentially be negative factors we
should not need we should not
necessarily promote IgG expression and
then finally to identify what the
optimal conditions for IgG maximization
would be so the first graph you see and
these are just examples of some of the
interactions you know based on the
analysis the first graph you see is that
analysis of the interaction between
glutimax and spite
so what we can see is that when you add
spice to yourself as a media the best of
cell culture media in this case of
optical media the red lines are the
glutimax conditions you know over time
we do see an increase in the IgG
expression over time with glutimax
but when we are tied to the same media
that has glutimax and that's the pitter
in the green lines we now see a
reduction in a GG expression so this
seems to suggest that pite does have a
negative effect on ieg growth whereas
glutimax has a positive effect and the
combination then lowers the FF of the
growth amongst another example would be
the addition of tied to the two
different buffers here so when we are
tied
hippies and that's the dot you know this
in the middle spot in the middle shows
that there's absolutely no effect you
know between spite and hippies well when
we add PI to a media that contains the
bioreactor buffer we now see an increase
in the IgG growth so the interaction of
tight with the bioreactor media
essentially improves or increases or as
a positive factor to IgG expression a
third example would be where you have
more than two interactions so in this
case you know we are adding Speight to a
system that only has glutimax and as you
can see the first two dots would be the
F aerospike with blue services was shown
in the first diagram where there's a
negative effect but when we add a third
component such as hippies buffa again we
don't see much of an improvement but if
that buffer in this case was bioreactor
buffer we do see now that suddenly the
algae growth then increases you know a
combination of tide glutimax bioreactor
Bafa now has a positive effect on the
growth you know the cross-media
condition so this tree grows are a very
big testament to the power of a full
factorial do e in being able to identify
what the best of optimal conditions
would be for any cell line development
as
Maria what we found with the IgE
qualification in the octet what we see
is that the different additives have
different effects with polyamine and
proteomics having a positive effect on
IgG growth whereas Parata pass by itself
you know have a negative effect on algae
growth spice also reduces the positive
effect that we see with glutimax but
then the combination of spider bharata
bhava and gruesome acts eventually then
does have a positive you know aside from
the algae growth so this kind of
analysis was done for all the
interactions and what we saw is that by
far a lot of the other factors or
combinations had negligible effect if
any at all on the IgG production so in
summary what we saw is that if we only
looked at the algae production from the
basal optical media alone we do obtain a
figure of about 8.8 micrograms per ml we
also saw that the highest condition the
best interactions produced as high as
fourteen point six maxwell's by ml in
IgG production whereas the lowest
condition gave us you know a reduction
of about 10% from the basal optical
production of eight point eight to about
7 point 8 microns per ml we also could
do a prediction based on the statics of
modeling and what we predicted was that
a combination of polyamine spired
glutimax and bioreactor Bafa would
produce as high as 13 point 6 microns by
ml in reality we did get the highest
condition being fourteen point six
microns per ml essentially we also did
predict that if we just look at base
into the vessel optical media alone the
model would give you a prediction of
ninety nine point six microns per ml
when in reality we did get only eight
point eight micrograms per ml you so the
prediction was about 42% higher than
what we actually you know obtained using
optical media so this design of
experiment you know the fairly good way
to run a fairly quick experiment using
two integrated systems the biomech
workstation in the octet HT
to be able to look at 96 different
interactions and be able to determine
which particular interactions or
supplements would not necessarily give
you any value in your cell life
development and their who would be a
waste of time and a waste of money
during the development process so to
look at other things now that we did
beyond the agagite growth I'm going to
turn it back over to Mike to continue
with the presentation thanks David
yeah that was a great explanation of how
we were able to achieve measurements on
the IgG production which was still the
main goal for the optimization process
but we did want to take it one step
further and see if we could establish
any sort of mechanism by which these
factors were having their effect and you
can imagine easily two different ways
that you could get an increase in IgG
production one would be essentially to
stimulate cell growth so you have the
more cells expressing the same level of
protein or it could be that you're
inducing more protein production so
essentially the same number of cells but
each of them producing more IgG ideally
if you can discriminate between these
two effects you might have the potential
to harness both of those such as by
increasing the number of cells initially
and then switching over to more of a
protein production model by changing the
additives so for this we turn to the
spectra max I 3x with minimax imaging
cytometer
shown to the right and this is from
molecular devices the blue portion of
the instrument is the spectrum max I 3 X
which is essentially a plate reader that
allows you to measure standard
measurements such as absorbance
fluorescents or luminescence at the well
level and if you add the orange
component the minimax imaging cytometer
this allows you to takes 4x images in
either bright field or two different
fluorescent wavelengths so you can
really get per cell data rather than
just well level data we actually took
two approaches to measuring cell growth
one was to just use standard bright
field cell imaging and another was to
use an absorbance that they by the
addition of X T T this is a reagent that
will just eventually turn into an orange
color depending that's based on the
number of cells per well it's very
straightforward assay it's just edie
incubate and read
and we automated this process on the
biomech as well and we'll discuss why we
use both of these approaches so shown
here is the first image of our show cell
lines that are grown just in standard
optical media and what you can see is
that the cells essentially form 3d
colonies in this condition this could
potentially result in undercounting
cells of only using an imaging assay
because of the nature of the colonies
however we were able to see some
differences with the different additives
and that the presence of glutimax
resulted in increased sizes of the cell
colonies suggesting it does have an
effect on cell growth we also noticed
that the addition of spite seemed to
increase the number of individual cells
between colonies so certainly just
looking at these images you can imagine
we saw higher cell count than we did in
the optical media alone and if we
combine those two despite with glutimax
you essentially see both effects larger
colonies as well as more cells in
between the colonies resulting in higher
cell counts to just kind of summarize
what that looks like across the board
again this would suggest that glutimax
in spite those two factors which we've
already seen can have positive effects
on IgG might likely be working through a
cell growth mechanism this also implies
that things such as poly mean which did
not seem to have an effect on cell
growth might be working through a
different pathways such as increasing
protein production and again this might
be a way of but perhaps staggering these
additives to increase your production
even further we also as I mentioned use
the xdt assay as another surrogate for
cell growth simply because we figured
this should not be affected by the 3d
morphology however because we have
different additives and different Wells
there is the chance that the chemistry
itself could be affected somehow by the
additives the good news is we saw a high
degree of similarities and that glutimax
had an increased effect on cell counts
in either method cell imaging or x CTSA
suggesting that this really does
reinforce the idea that glutimax is
inducing cell growth the same is true
for the Speight plus bioreactor buffer
that we saw originally had the
back on IgG titer as well however we did
see some differences
compared to our cell imaging for the one
example being efficient feed a which
basically had no effect on IgG titer and
perhaps even a negative effect on cell
counts by imaging actually had a
positive effect on xt t suggesting that
we did have some disparate results and
we might need a third a state to try and
distinguish between these two one way to
do that might be to trypsin eyes the
cell colonies and either replate them
for additional imaging or possibly count
them through another mechanism such as
flow cytometry or other cell counters so
that pretty much sums up the data that
we have for this level of IgG
optimization through changing the media
components but there were some caveats
that we learned through this process one
is that as one might expect evaporation
can significantly impact your results so
the data we showed for IgG titer was
from a four day incubation and because
we're using the 384-well format the edge
effect where evaporation is most
prominent on the outer wells can have a
significant impact that's summarized by
showing looking at the Seavey's of our
replicate wells if we only look at wells
that had all four of their replicates on
the interior of the plate
the average CV across samples was only
2.9 percent a remarkably low level for
this type of Biological assay however if
we compare that to the octet readings of
our quadruple gate values where some of
the wells were on the edges the outer
portion of the plate you can see that CV
increases to nine point six percent
indicating there was a significant edge
effect on this plate and for this the
edge wells were excluded from the
calculations and that's one more reason
why it was very relieving to have the
statistical software be able to predict
the models so that you're not entirely
dependent on a single data point for
your analysis we also found that some of
the additives can affect the octet
baseline
one example is linoleic acid oleic acid
in albumin there was a combination of
these three factors that we thought
about adding but we noticed that there
was a spike in the baseline every time
these factors were added
and because they would not be present in
every well it would be very difficult to
discriminate real from false positive
effects on the IgG production so because
of this this was eliminated from the
screen and we've already pushed on some
of the caveats we saw with the cell
imaging and X DT and that morphology can
possibly play a role in getting misread
cell counts as well as the different
additives could be affecting the xct
chemistry or evaporation can also have
an effect so that's another reason why
we wanted to have these somewhat
complementary yet also somewhat
redundant ways of measuring cell growth
so to bring it back to the process of
cell line development again we were
really only demonstrating one aspect of
a much longer process really focusing on
the optimization step of the workflow
and we showed how each of the three
components the automation for sample
processing the imaging or absorbance
reads as well as the protein production
and protein quantification reads on the
octet really enabled this step to be put
through at a relatively high throughput
again for such fast processing and fast
analysis we could increase this process
even further to include additional
factors or additional concentrations
with relative ease however what's
important to note is that all of these
instruments in some way shape or form
can be used throughout the entire cell
line development workflow such examples
include using the octet to do the
protein production assessment of large
numbers of monoclonal wells as well as
using an imaging whether it be the I 3 X
with minimax or other imaging components
to track cell growth and to establish
monoclonal T during the process as well
the automation can certainly be used to
automate each and every one of these
components to basically enable whether
it be a cell line development or any of
the sample processing needed for the
type of analyses we've discussed so the
throughput concern has certainly been
answered with each of these instruments
but if we want to look at the sample and
data integrity
what really becomes more powerful is
that you can actually integrate these
devices all together to ensure that
sample
process from beginning to end of this
workflow in one continuous fashion and
the film one example of a fully
integrated cell line development system
is shown to the lower right where the
biomech is once again there to prepare
samples plate cells transfer media for
analysis and then the analyzers can be
integrated with the robotic arm and
those plates can be then processed on
individual analyzers and sent back to
the incubator for additional incubation
not only does this ensure sample
integrity because there's less need for
manual intervention but each plate can
be bar coded to ensure that every plate
is being processed at a known time in a
known fashion we also have a software
component to the idea of data integrity
so as the samples move through the
process our dart data tracking software
can basically append each new piece of
data as it's generated to each plate to
ensure that you don't have to go back
and try and figure out what plate
corresponds to what sample which
corresponds to which data all of that is
brought forward throughout the process
and in fact that data as it is learned
can be used to drive additional
pipetting one example would be as you
identify which clones have your highs
producing IgG the biomech can take this
information and then automate the
replating and expansion of these cells
into larger well plates we also have a
software solution for the challenge of
scheduling campaigns as I mentioned you
can go from very low throughput where
you're maybe transfecting one to two
wells all the way up to very high
throughput where you're screening
hundreds of thousands of clones to
establish monoclonal 'ti and IgG
production but because you have to have
a system that can handle the maximum
sample number you also want to find ways
to stagger these campaigns so your
system is getting the maximal usage and
our Sammis scheduling software is the
method by which you can establish what
samples are currently on the system when
the automation or analytical devices are
going to be in use when samples will be
coming off of the system and when you'll
have more room in your incubator for
example or whatever your rate limiting
step may be so again just another way
that you can get the full maximum power
out of your fully integrated cell line
development system so with that we'd
like to
up-up hopefully we've demonstrated how
we used our design of experiment
approach to identify positive reagents
for IgG production as well as some
pretty unique interactions that would
not have been detected had we not been
using this design of experiment approach
and we were able to identify conditions
that should increase our AGG production
between 42 and 66% whether using the
statistical modeling software or whether
you're using the actual output numbers
obviously partnerships were key for this
type of work to have expertise and
automation protein production
measurements and imaging or other types
of analyses really bring together this
project and finally we showed how
integrating these devices the biomass
the octet HDX and the spectra max I 3x
with minimax or other imaging imaging
instruments can really enable a complete
cell line development workflow and how
samples and data can then be tracked
throughout the system for more
information you can visit biologics by
Danaher comm and then we've got a few
disclaimers that we need to put up there
and after that thank you very much for
your attention and we're happy to take
questions
thank you dr. Kowalski and dr. APO for
that informative presentation
it's time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green shoe and a button at
the lower left of the presentation
window touch your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button we'll answer as many of
your questions as we have time for if we
are unable to get to your questions you
will receive a follow-up email after the
presentation for the Q&A portion we will
also have Sean Alvarado field
application scientist from molecular
devices let's get started our first
question is for Sean what automatic
measurements can you make with the
minimax imaging psycho Saitama tur
without adding fluorescent dyes so one
of the best features about the minimax
imaging site ometer is the ability to do
the stain free analysis so
if you're looking to do cell counts if
you're looking to assess confluency
using our field analysis tool you can do
classification with morphology all this
can be done without any dyes so when you
use them in emacs you can actually take
your cell line perform the initial
analysis telling the system what does a
cell what is not a cell and then further
you can classify based on morphology for
example if you're doing an infective 'ti
assay you could select cells that are
infected and uninfected and once you set
this up for the cells that you're going
to be doing you can actually save this
as a protocol to be used every time
you're going to run the assay and making
the process automated and not requiring
any dyes
thank you the next question is for David
what what is the specificity sensitivity
on these instruments yes thank you for
the question so the specificity for the
octet instruments or the octet
biosensors who depend on what you
analyze you know your biological
molecule of analysis you know is so for
example if your target analysis is an
IgG such as we have talked about this
webinar then your balance would
potentially have a protein a or protein
g you know on it the biosensors that we
currently sell used recombinant protein
a recombinant protein G where the
potential BAC or albumin binding
epitopes have been removed so there
should be specific to any FC region of
an IgG or potentially you know fusion
proteins you know so the systems are
generally specific but just like with
any given biological assay you know
sometimes one may need to as I develop
to remove potential nonspecific you know
binding when it comes to sensitivity all
the octet instruments that I talked
about today should be able to measure as
low as zero point zero five micrograms
per ml in a direct assay so a direct our
circuit is one where you are dipping the
sensors into the reagent in a one-step
assay however if you have concentrations
lower than 0.05 microns per ml then you
can build the a say in what we call an
indirect assay such as a sandwich Eliza
assay where you amplify signals using
polymerization chemistry's in that case
you can lower the sensitivity work to as
low as 10 to around 4 ml when doing a
quantitation assay
thank you the next question is for David
does the octet quantitation approach
apply only to IgG samples if not what
might the process look like for a
recombinant protein just good question
on thanks again
so IgG quantitation is what we did in
this webinar however the systems can be
used for any type of quantitation so
long as you have a capture molecule and
by that really what I mean is that if
you had a recombinant protein for
example you could potentially immobilize
a specific antibody towards that
particular protein and use that nearly
customized bio sensor to be able to do
direct quantitation either so it's not
quite the case that it's only for a GDQ
mutation it can also be used for
recombinant proteins but in that case
you would have to develop what we call
customized biosensors those customers
biosensors once developed installed
could then be used in direct acid where
they're being dipped in simply into the
analyte for one step assay
thank you the next question is for Mike
can automation be used to optimize
culture growth conditions of bacterial
expression systems for example ecoli for
the parameters such as temperature time
of harvest
shaking speed and OD yeah that's a great
question it's a similar application in
the sense of you might be looking for
something similar for protein production
but very different in the sense of now
dealing with prokaryotic cells from a
liquid handling perspective there's
they're very similar right you're still
moving things from one position to
another
but one consideration might be a lot of
times people working in bacteria are
more used to say round based place such
as petri dishes ideally you can do
things in an SBS format so basically
standard microtiter plate formats
perhaps using deep well placed to get
some of your liquid culture or as I
mentioned before the span eight
pipetting system does work well with
tubes so if you're doing things in a
shaking tube type of platform that would
also work as far as changing temperature
that's one thing to consider when it
comes to what you're integrating or what
some devices you might include obviously
if you're working with multiple samples
in one plate that plate can only be
incubated one temperature
but you could have smaller incubators or
even some on Dec heating and cooling
since you wouldn't necessarily need the
co2 typically associated with mammalian
cell culture and so we could do some of
that incubation and shaking on Dec or
through smaller integrated incubators as
well so long answer to a short question
as yes you definitely can optimize that
type of workflow with bacteria and using
a lot of the same devices heating and
cooling you can measure your OD with a
plate reader or other such analyzers so
definitely would be feasible great thank
you so much the next question is for
Mike were these experiments performed
with adherent or suspension cells yeah
that's also a great question
so cho cells are obviously able to be
grown typically under either conditions
suspension or adherence and what these I
would kind of call these loosely
adherent what we found is that after
multiple passages in the optic show the
cells even if we started them in
adherent culture would eventually switch
to suspension however we were doing this
in the first one or two passages in this
media so they were still adherent to the
bottom of the plate we have been doing
some similar work for cell line
development working with suspension show
cells and depending on the plates you
use the workflow is very similar but if
you want to take an imaging component it
does help to work with some plates like
the co-star I'll forget what they're
called but it's basically a plate that
loosely binds some suspension cells but
they can be easily released from the
plate just through pipetting so again
the system should work with either it's
just you need to take a couple things
into consideration depending on the
analysis that you're using but the octet
would be unaffected or should be
unaffected by the presence of cells so
if some do get transferred it should not
affect your your reads and again the
imaging there's ways that you can have
the cells settle to the bottom of the
plate and stay loosely adherent for more
accurate imaging thank you the next
question is for Mike wanted to know if
it was possible to build or or Beckman
has a custom integration for the octet
or are potentially working on one for
this system yes we do so then
the image that I showed the obviously
very difficult to say in a small image
but the cell line development system
that we demonstrated did have an
integrated octet and we've demonstrated
that in the past it is able to be
directly controlled through the
automation where like I said a robotic
handler would place the plate in the
octet for the read and basically
essentially push the Go button the data
would then be sent back to the
automation and as I mentioned that data
could be directly used to drive hit
picking and other applications on the
instrument so yes the octet HDX and as
David mentioned I believe that 384 have
both been integrated with biomech liquid
handlers thank you the next question is
for either David or Mike was there any
analysis of how unattached culture would
affect the cells yes I can start with
that one I think we sort of touched on
that earlier as I mentioned what we did
was using it here in cultures but again
they the cells can be grown in both
suspension or in adherent cultures as I
mentioned some of the work we're doing
now is with suspension cultures I've not
done a direct comparison we've actually
changed to a different media we're using
cho growth a for molecular devices for
the suspension cultures and the cells
are still expressing IgG but I've not
done a direct comparison to how we did
this this type of analysis but the same
same rules would apply you would
certainly be able to do a very similar
approach for optimization and then just
plate the suspension cells on top and
still process them using the octet David
anything bad no I think you're correct I
don't think I have anything to add to
that great thank you so much the next
question is for either of you it is the
effect stronger if you see glutimax plus
the spite and buffer then just glutimax
I noticed there was a difference from
the baseline but was not clear on this
difference I think so I think there was
a fairly slight difference that might
you can chime in here but what I did
that indeed when you had glutimax plus
pi and the bioreactor buffer you see a
fairly slight improvement from when he
just had both of us alone the question
in my mind is whether the difference is
significant enough to justify the cost
of adding spite in the bioreactor buffer
as opposed to just having glutamic by
itself you know so that's an analysis
that I'm not sure we've done Mike but
there indeed was a very slight
difference between the three combined
versus just glutimax alone yeah David is
exactly right so I pulled up slide 13
which hopefully can roughly demonstrate
that the green line and the third graph
is higher than the red line in the first
graph so there was an improvement with
the spy plus bioreactor buffer according
to our statistical analysis as well as
our actual readings but David is correct
that you would have to do the kind of
cost-benefit analysis of is this worth
the additional cost of the reagents and
and we didn't necessarily look at that
but but yes there was an improvement
with all of the factors that as we
mentioned the predicted best condition
would be glutimax plus polyamine plus by
plus bioreactor buffer but whether you
can get most of the way there with just
glutimax certainly seems to be the case
so again to do the kind of cost-benefit
analysis of what the reagents cost would
definitely be worthwhile looking in
thank you we'll wrap up with one last
question and that question is for Mike
which software tool was used to design
your do e and generate biomech scripts
so two different questions there I guess
the first one is that we use design
expert from stat es but as David said uh
you can use a variety of different
statistical software for this type of
application in the past we've had a
software that was used to then directly
translate that into biomech script that
was not what I did here this was
basically just I developed a list of
factors and then essentially figured out
the best way to put them on the plate so
that that they they would necessarily
work in a reasonable
to allow me to get to a 96-well format
so there there could be some tools that
can help you with the statistical design
software and then again to create the
the biomech script or the biomech method
was basically just things that I worked
out the land on in my head and just
wrote in a few different transfer steps
I would like to once again thank dr.
Kowalski and doctoral Pio for their
presentation do you have any final
comments for myself just thank you again
for attending and certainly if there's
additional questions we haven't gotten
to we'll certainly try and follow up
with those but yes thanks very much for
the opportunity and thanks everyone for
attending yes I would also like to thank
everyone for attending and they'll put
you to be able to you know speak to you
all about this webinar I'd like to add
that if you do need any more you know
information on how the octet works of
bli in general please let us know thank
you before we go I want to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye